THERE TO REPORT FOR OUR AUDIENCE
ON IT.
SEE YOU LATER AT 11:00 P.M.
.
>> Reporter: I ENJOY BEING WITH
YOU.
THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
>> STEVE: I'LL HAVE MORE LATER
IN THE SHOW.
BUT, FIRST, THE ESTABLISHMENT IS
IN A MELTDOWN OVER THE PREVIOUS
SUMMIT, THE G7 SUMMIT.
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S CRITICISM OF
ALLIES OVER TRADE IS UNPRECEDENT
THE, THEY SCREAM.
HE'S UNDERMINING SOMETHING THAT
THEY CALL THE RULES-BASED
INTERNATIONAL ORDER.
THAT, APPARENTLY, IS ALL THEY
NEED TO SAY.
END OF DISCUSSION.
THE ONLY THING THEY CARE ABOUT
IS STYLE.
THEY DON'T ENGAGE WITH THE
SUBSTANCE AT ALL.
THESE POMPOUS OF THE
INTERNATIONAL ELITE, WORLD
LEADERS WITH THEIR BRAND
COMMUNICATE PROMPTED BY TIME
SERVING DIPLOMATS WHO THINK THEY
REALLY RUN THE SHOW.
THE UNACCOUNTABLE DIPLOMAT WHO
ARE BIG STOOGES FOR BUSINESS.
THE AFTER DINNER PONTIFICATORS
WHO GLIDE SMOOTHLY OVER THE
CATASTROPHE WITHOUT EVER
ACKNOWLEDGING THE SLIGHTEST
MISTAKE.
AND, OF COURSE, THE GULLIBLE
COMMENTATORS AND JOURNALISTS WHO
LAP UP ALL OF THIS SELF SERVING
ELITIST RUBBISH WHILE PREVAILING
THEMSELF AS THE TRUTH.
WHEN YOU SEE THESE PEOPLE
ROUNDING ON PRESIDENT TRUMP FOR
DARING TO QUESTION THEIR WORLD
VIEW, THE PITY PHRASE COMES TO
MIND.
I, WHY, I.
INTELLECT YESTERDAY IDIOT.
WHAT IS THIS RULES-BASED
INTERNATIONAL ORDER THAT THE IYI
ARE SO ATTACHED TO?
HERE IN AMERICA AND ACROSS THE
WESTERN WORLD, THE RULE-BASED
INTERNATIONAL ORDER MADE THE
RICH RICHER AND WORKING PEOPLE
POORER AS INCOMES WENT DOWN AND
JOBS WENT AWAY.
IT RIPPED APART THE SOCIAL
FABRIC HELPING CREATE THE TWIN
FACTORS AND COMMUNITY
INTEGRATION.
IT UNDERMINED FACING GOVERNMENT
AND DEMOCRACY AS CITIZENS SO YOU
IT DIDN'T MATTER WHO THEY VOTED
FOR IN ACTUAL ELECTIONS THAT END
UP WITH THE SAME POLICIES
REGARDLESS.
THE TRADE RULES OF THE
INTERNATIONAL ORDER ARE TILTED
AGAINST AMERICA, ALLOWING
RAMPANT PROTECTIONISM BY THE EU
AND EPIC ABUSE BY CHINA.
THE RULES-BASED INTERNATIONAL
ORDER DIDN'T STOP RUSSIA
INVADING UKRAINE.
IT DIDN'T STOP IRAN
DESTABILIZING THE MIDDLE EAST.
IT DIDN'T STOP THE RISE OF AL
QAEDA AND ISIS.
IT DIDN'T STOP CHINA GETTING TO
THE BRINK OF WORLD DOMINATION
AND IT DIDN'T STOP NORTH KOREA
FROM HAVING NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
ALTHOUGH TO THE BITTER
DISAPPOINTMENT, DONALD TRUMP
JUST MIGHT.
WHEN I WORKED WITH AN ADVISOR, I
WANTED PRIME MINISTER DAVID
CAMERON TO CANCEL THE G8 SUMMIT
WHEN IT WAS BRITAIN'S TERM TO
HOST IT.
I LOVE PRESIDENT TRUMP CALL TIME
ON 50 YEARS OF EE
ON 50 YEARS OF ELI
ON 50 YEARS OF ELITI
ON 50 YEARS OF ELITIST
ON 50 YEARS OF ELITIST FA
ON 50 YEARS OF ELITIST FAIL
ON 50 YEARS OF ELITIST FAILUR
ON 50 YEARS OF ELITIST FAILURE.
BUT DOING THINGS UNPRECEDENTED
IS THE VERY DEFINITION OF DONALD
TRUMP MANDATE.
HE WAS ELECTED TO CHANGE THINGS.
NOT KEEP THEM THE SAME.
THE ELITIST HATE-FILLED HISS
TEAR YEAH SHOWS THEIR --
HYSTERIA SHOWS THEIR TRULL
COLOR.
THEY LOVE THE OLD ORDER BECAUSE
THEY AND THEIR RICH FRIENDS
BENEFIT IN IT.
HOW DISGRACEFUL THAT THEY HOWL
IN PROTEST WHEN PRESIDENT TRUMP